لذلك عندما يتعلق الأمر بالحرب
سيكون هذا أمرًا مثيرًا للاهتمام حقًا ، فعندما
تنظر إلى ما لديك هنا على
الخريطة الرئيسية ، يكون لديك احتمال أن
يأتي الروس ليس فقط من
الشرق ولكن أيضًا من الجنوب
هذه الاتجاهات هذا ما
يريدون القيام به إذا ذهبت إلى
خريطة أكثر تفصيلاً للجبهة الشرقية على سبيل
المثال القتال الكبير الذي لديك
حول سوليدار حول باكموت ، تصبح كل تلك
المناطق هنا رمزًا
لما يريد الروس القيام به الآن
باهاموت في حد ذاته ليس
مهمًا من الناحية الاستراتيجية ، ولكن
على طريقنا السريع الرئيسي يسير على هذا النحو ،
وإذا كان بإمكانهم استخدام هذا الطريق السريع ، فمن
المحتمل أن يكون بوابة
للروس للمضي قدمًا إلى
منطقة السيطرة الأوكرانية لكنهم
ذاهبون إليها.  يحاول essence التغلب على
حالة الجمود التي يحاول الأوكرانيون
تجاوز عقارب الساعة ويحاولون
تحقيقها حتى يتمكنوا من محاربة
الروس وعلى الأقل الاحتفاظ بهم
هنا ولكن هدفهم الحقيقي هو القضاء على
الروس من هذا  جزء هنا ما
يسمى بالجسر البري حيث
يريد الأوكرانيون التحرك في
الاتجاه المعاكس وإخراج
الروس بهذه الطريقة وإجبارهم على الخروج
من البلاد